we've all felt the sting that comes from
watching a beloved game series go cold
it's like remembering an old friend that
you last played online with over 2000
days ago great gaming memories can live
on in our hearts and minds and with the
increased ease of
backwards-compatibility
are becoming easier to revisit but some
amazing game series have been dormant
for way too long and all we want to do
is welcome them back with open arms join
me as we spiral down memory lane and
look back on seven game series that need
a serious comeback like a terrifying
gory flash-in-the-pan
dead space came and went it burst into
my life in 2008 and stopped returning my
calls after 2013's Dead Space 3 it was a
wonderful mix of Resident Evil and event
horizon with some gruesome mortal combat
deaths that you wouldn't want your
parents to walk in on they were so over
the top that it spawned a hilarious ad
campaign for the sequel Oh fooling them
- there were comics in animated film a
Wii spin-off and even rumors of a film
adaptation with John Carpenter directing
fans were passionate about the dead
space series and were hopeful for more
especially after the cliffhanger ending
from the third game but alas it wasn't
meant to be and just after five years
dead space was no more developer
Visceral Games was shut down and the
series was put on ice at this point we
can only hope EA has future plans for
the series and until then we'll just
listen to creator and director Glen
Schofield gush about dead space as we
hold back our tears I enjoyed making
that space so much that you know
hopefully someday I'll make one of those
games again
[Music]
[Applause]
car combat games will never go out of
style they're easy to play fun for
multiplayer and have a history of
awesome soundtracks the twisted metal
series was a prime example with numerous
games launched for PlayStation consoles
beginning in 1995 the series had its
share of ups and downs but the later
games including twisted metal black and
2012's twisted metal did ride by most
fans with graphical updates the addition
of online multiplayer and memorable
characters added to the roster
unfortunately the series went quiet
after the 2012 release of twisted metal
with developer eat sleep play shutting
its doors in 2017 since then we've been
living in a world without a next-gen
modern twisted metal game and I hate it
the timeless formula of the twisted
metal series proved that it could work
in any gaming generation a new entry or
remake of part two what easily remind
everyone why the series was so damn cool
personally this one breaks my heart
nothing brings back memories like the
opening level of 1999's Syphon Filter
Gabe Logan defending the streets of
Washington DC with nothing but a
silenced handgun and the best run cycle
ever programmed into a game
who else remembers rolling into glass
doors throwing grenades impossibly far
and using the Taser to completely
incinerate enemies the Syphon Filter
series had an incredible start on the
PlayStation 1 where the first three
titles each received Greatest Hits
releases since then gaben the gang have
slowly fizzled out
with less than popular sequels for the
ps2 and PSP doing nothing to keep the
passion forgave Logan alive not all hope
is lost for the series though after
Syphon Filter to eidetic became Ben's
studio and the team is still around
today their latest game days gone even
makes reference to Gabe's overpowered
taser all we can do is hope that they're
listening
Capcom check survival-horror check
dinosaurs yeah check in 1999 what more
could you ask for
after the gleaming success of the
Resident Evil series Capcom took the
same formula and added dinosaurs if you
don't remember the 90s was a fantastic
decade for our prehistoric friends
causing problems for humans we had
dinosaurs the TV show - Jurassic Park
movies and of course Reptar naturally it
was the perfect time for a dinosaur
video game while other games like Tomb
Raider and Tarak put the player up
against the occasional dinosaur none of
those games mastered the fear leading up
to encountering them quite like Dino
Crisis look at this I was 11 when this
came out and watching the scene maybe my
dinosaur one size fits all pajamas after
a successful sequel and this the series
went dark rumors of a return have
circulated for years even as late as
2016 when Monster Hunter online producer
Tao Wei she expressed interest in a
remake with the way remakes have been
going for Capcom lately we fans would
like to formally give this idea the
greenlight
[Music]
[Applause]
we were so close so close to having a
new Silent Hill game silent hill's was
to be a terrifying collaboration between
the brilliant minds of Hideo Kojima
Guillermo del Toro and horror manga
artists gingy ito the hype came to a
head when a playable teaser or PT
dropped in August of 2014
sadly it wasn't meant to be a day of
Kojima was on increasingly rocky terms
with Konami
and little by little the project began
to crumble silent Hills was forever
shelved and Hideo Kojima left Konami in
2015 as suddenly as it appeared Konami
removed the game from the PlayStation
Store and while fans download and backup
their precious copies of PT there hasn't
been talk of a comeback since while the
whole experience ended up giving us
norman reedus and the funky fetus known
outside of my head as death stranding it
was hard to watch Silent Hill fall again
later entries in the series for the ps3
and PS Vita were less than favorable so
this was a perfect opportunity for
everyone involved to make something
great something special that would
breathe new air into a classic series
and introduce new terrifying years to
come
[Music]
we all remember when it happened in 2017
then community manager at EA Daniel
Langdon tweeted skateboard at the time
the series had been dormant for more
than seven years
fans were hopeful and vocal about a
long-awaited sequel to 2010's skate
three so to see this coming directly
from an EA figurehead
sounded like all of our dreams were
coming true especially after the
backlash of Activision's Tony Hawk's Pro
Skater 5 this was the best time for EA
to give the hands what they wanted sadly
a few days later CEO of EA Andrew Wilson
killed everyone's buzz by stating there
were no plans to make skateboard fans
were and still are devastated to make
matters worse in 2018 EA reopened the
skate 2 & 3 online servers before their
press conference at e3 the timing seemed
right for EA to discuss a skate comeback
why else will they do something like
that well skate was not discussed that
day and since then fans and trolls alike
have been asking about skateboard across
all of EA social media when I heard this
I thought it was a joke but no if you go
on to any one of their posts you will
see a comment section flooded with skate
for comments will EA ever give in to the
demands of fans or will they behave like
that teacher that doesn't begin the
lecture until the class completely
quiets down now wait Jack Dunn
after the critical successes of the
grand theft auto and Max Payne series
Rockstar Vancouver and Rockstar North
launched bully in 2006 while it didn't
do gangbusters at launch when compared
to other rockstar titles it got plenty
of attention selling 1.5 million copies
in its first two years despite the usual
controversy Rockstar titles faced at
launch the game attained a cult
following and fans were eager for a
follow up title what we got instead was
an HD remaster in 2008 and a mobile port
in 2016 this one is a little harder to
gripe about because it appeared that a
sequel was in the works shortly after
the release of Red Dead Redemption in
2010 rockstar began to work on bully 2
according to an article by a video game
chronicle the sequel was being worked on
for 18 months before being cancelled in
2013 unfortunately this was also around
the time Rockstar Vancouver the original
development team closed its doors in
2012 despite all of the setbacks and
being shelved rumors continued to pile
up online about an eventual return to
Bulworth Academy we all know how
tight-lipped Rockstar can be for better
or worse so all we can do is wait what
do you think will come first bully 2 GTA
6 or Rockstar table-tennis 2
that's it for our list feeling angry sad
or just old me too and I know there were
several other games considered so if you
want to see more mournfully click that
like button and I'll be back to ruin
your day faster than you can say left 4
dead 3 until then
mope with me in the comments spam FS to
pay respects and I'll see you next time
[Music]
you
[Music]